oui oui nous allons y arriver alors
quand vous dites nous nous allons j'ai
envie de demander qui va parce qu'en
fait il faut en effet prendre la plume
et faire ce travail de bénédictin vous
avez décrit et convaincre qui est là je
fais le lien avec oui mais je fais le
lien avec et franchement cela donc qui
est président de la cgpme mais qui est
d'abord chef d'entreprise qui peut
s'exprimer assez ce double titre j'ai
envie de dire on revient beaucoup sur le
paritarisme
on a le sentiment qu'il est à bout de
souffle aujourd'hui et quand on vous
écoute tous les deux bertrand martinot
et paul henri antonmattei on voit bien
qu'on peut plus continuer comme ça par
contre et vous venez de le dire
vous avez une place les corps
intermédiaires qui est primordial alors
quelle est la place qu'on vous donne
aujourd'hui quelle est la place que vous
souhaiteriez avoir pour que le fameux
code du travail deviennent plus
efficaces
ça c'est la première question est pour
reprendre vos propos droit syndical
dense et touffu
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi
effectivement quand on voit le code du
travail on se demande qui le maîtrisent
aujourd'hui donc quelle est votre
analyse vous de ce qui est en train de
se mettre en route quand même qui est
cette idée qu'on peut signer des accords
dans les entreprises qu'ils primerait
sur des accords plus nationaux entre
guillemets sauf que on vient de voir
avec l'exemple de smart que on soumet à
référendum dans une entreprise une
décision sur le temps de travail les
salaires et donc on fait évoluer les
choses
mais derrière les organisations
syndicales de salariés bloquent donc ça
pour les citoyens c'est assez
incompréhensible et à c'est inadmissible
puisque on se dit qu'un accord
majoritaire dans une entreprise devrait
pouvoir aboutir à faire évoluer les
choses
alors moi je bois du petit lait par
rapport à tout ce que j'entends parce
que je partage complètement l'analyse
je suis avant tout un praticien du droit
du travail chef d'entreprise évidemment
je suis partenaire social à présent la
cgpme et je fais le même constat à
savoir qu'effectivement le paritarisme
et à bout de souffle mais au niveau
sommitale ce qu'au niveau les
entreprises
le dialogue dans les pme il existe au
quotidien c'est à dire que j'étais vent
debout lorsque
certains disaient qu'il fallait mettre
en place des commissions paritaires
régionales pour les tpe les entreprises
de moins de onze salariés parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de dialogue social dans
les très petites entreprises et que
quatre millions trois cent mille
salariés n'étaient pas représentés mais
alors enfin bon je suis tombé de ma
chaise moi quand j'ai lu c'est la
première fois parce que parce que enfin
je veux dire c'est c'est une vision du
dialogue social qui est complètement
mais mais décalée par rapport à ce qui
se passe dans la réalité alors dire
qu'il n'ya pas de moments de tensions
dans une entreprise c'est faux il suffit
d'être deux pour s'aimer ou se détester
et puis parfois ces variables un jour on
sème un jour aux états mais bref s'ils
sont faits les relations humaines
donc ce qui est intéressant dans le
débat d'aujourd'hui c'est que dans tout
le spectre politique
j'ai l'impression que la question de
fond est en train d'être posée est ce
que nous sommes capables nous au plus
près du terrain de faire en sorte de
s'organiser pour que dans nos
entreprises les choses se passent pour
le mieux
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça et je
trouve que ce débat est extrêmement
intéressant et qu'il faut l'encourager
parce que c'est une vraie révolution
dans ce pays de voir la façon dont on
peut dialoguer dans les entreprises
c'est un piège effectivement si nous n'y
sommes pas préparés
c'est à dire que je ne crois pas plus je
plus je réfléchis à cette chose-là puis
je réfléchis à ce dossier
il faudra du temps parce qu'il y aura
des résistances aux changements y
compris le camp patronal
parce que nous sommes habitués depuis
plus de 50 ans à faire en sorte que tout
vient d'en haut pour savoir ce qu'on
doit faire en bas or aujourd'hui je
trouve qu'une belle chose c'est que
d'une part l'opinion publique et le bon
sens est en train de triompher par
rapport aux politiques et aux
partenaires sociaux
donc ça je trouve ça excellent c'est à
dire que dans une petite entreprise
lorsque une commande importante arrive
qu'est ce qu'on fait on commence vers le
cap du travail pour savoir comment on va
répondre à cette commande absolument pas
si on commence par ça en fera pour fera
rien donc on fait on fait et parfois on
est en dehors des clous et c'est là où
tout se corse lorsque
lorsque arrive la visite de la
patrouille ça peut être l'inspecteur du
travail
ça peut être un délégué syndical qui dit
aulas stop ce que vous faites vous êtes
en dehors des clous
je vous fais un rappel à la loi sinon ça
va pas aller voilà et là d'un seul coup
vous vivez ça en tant que chef
d'entreprise avec une extrême violence
parce que vous qu'est ce que vous faites
vous ayez simplement de répondre à
l'obligation de résultat vous avez
vis-à-vis de votre client et puis
vis-à-vis vos salariés parce que tout ça
fait en sorte que la commande que vous
avez accepté va permettre de donner à
manger à vos salariés
donc le fait effectivement de pouvoir au
plus près du terrain
donner aux acteurs la possibilité de
décider leur propre organisation
ça c'est une belle chose il faut
l'encourager deuxièmement il faut pas se
mentir vous l'avez très bien dit
beaucoup d'entreprises de petites
entreprises n'ont pas la capacité
ne serait-ce que technique ne serait-ce
que en termes juridiques de poser un
accord et le rôle de la branche
professionnelle est primordial donc avec
le foisonnement actuel les branches
effectivement il va falloir regrouper
tout ça pour quoi
la branche est importante parce qu'il
faut éviter la loi de la jungle tout
simplement il faut que dans un même
secteur d'activité on va dire que les
règles sommitale que le bordage et bien
le bornage soit équilibré pour qu'on
n'est pas du grand n'importe quoi
voilà donc ça c'est important
techniquement je ne suis pas un
spécialiste du droit du travail mais je
ne vois pas comment on peut envisager
tous à terme sans toiletter le code du
travail
est ce que j'appellerais moelleux le
droit conventionnel
parce que faut pas oublier que nos
partenaires sociaux nous nous sommes mis
nous-mêmes défaire avec lesquels nous
avançons aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
beaucoup d'accords conventionnelles sont
encore plus rigide que le droit du
travail lui même
c'est pour ça que ce que nous
développons et ce en quoi nous militons
à la cgpme c'est de faire du dialogue
social serein et non en train
c'est la raison pour laquelle lors de
lagny sur la formation professionnelle
sur le titre 1
nous étions vent debout noah la cgpme
nous n'avons pas si voulu signer cet
accord pourquoi parce qu'il oblige le
chef d'entreprise à faire un entretien
individuel tous les deux ans
s'il ne fait pas cet entretien
individuel tous les deux ans avec ses
salariés il y a potentiellement 3500
euros d'amendé par salarié je ne dis pas
que l'entretien individuel est un
mauvais outil managérial bien au
contraire je les ai mis en place dans
mon entreprise il ya quinze ans c'est
excellent sauf que lorsque une chose
naturelle on en fait une chose obligé eh
bien on tue la chose naturelle
c'est-à-dire que qu'est ce qui se passe
dans l'entreprise à cela on a sorti la
liste du personnel
on a regardé depuis combien de temps on
avait fait nos entretiens individuels on
est allé faire contresigner ces
entretiens individuels à chacun des
salariés pour éviter en cas de visite de
la patrouille d'avoir de 3500 euros
damende qu'est ce que je fais moins
chefs d'entreprise comme boulot mais
c'est nul je veux dire je ne devrais pas
concentré mon temps à faire des choses
comme ça je devais me concentrer à
développer l'entreprise allait voir les
clients oem occupe la cgpme bref je veux
dire on s'est complètement laissé
enfermer lorsque vous passez le seuil de
49 à 50
votre métier change vous devenez un
moitié des rh - tié responsable
illustratif nouveau dans votre
entreprise pourquoi parce que vous
n'avez pas les moyens
premièrement d'embaucher un drh
d'embaucher un conseil juridique et
c'est donc votre votre activité est en
train de complètement se transformer et
bien il faudrait regarder avec une chose
pragmatique
qu'est ce qui ferait que notre activité
ne se transforme pas complètement le
dernier point sur lequel je voudrais
rebondir et qui sera un sujet que vous
aborderez tout à l'heure c'est la
présence syndicale
force est de constater sur ton
territoire la pauvreté de nos
interlocuteurs sur le thème du dialogue
c'est à dire que lorsque vous devez
renouveler tous les quatre ans vos
instances représentatives du personnel
vous écrivez aux centrales syndicales de
votre département
parce qu'elles sont invités à ce qu'on
appelle ce fameux premier tour syndicale
et là j'aime mieux vous expliquer je
sais pas si certains d'entre vous ont
cette expérience mais moi je les ai vus
à plusieurs reprises vous recevez un
coup de fil d'abord il arrive à voir
votre téléphone portable alors personne
ne leur a donné ça c'est ils sont très
forts et moi la dernière fois c'était il
ya un an et demi on me dit écoutez
monsieur instinct j'ai reçu votre
courrier
qu'est-ce qu'il a rédigée j'écoutais
basse et moi avec
voilà avec le responsable stratégie
l'entreprise va écouter ces cellules
votre courrier nul en termes de droit
elle est mal rédigé il avait raison mais
ça a commencé comme ça il dit monsieur
cela il devait venir dans votre
entreprise
je viens négocier dans votre entreprise
le code électoral pour les instances
représentatives du personnel
il a tout à fait le droit alors je
commence à être un petit peu voilà
habitué à ce genre de choses mais c'est
d'une violence extrême
vous avez quelqu'un qui ne connaît
absolument pas votre aventure
d'entreprises qui ne connaît absolument
pas votre personnel qui ne vous
connaissent qui ne vous connaît pas qui
vous interpellent comme si c'était un
agent de police judiciaire et vous ne
pouvez rien dire rien
vous ne pouvez simplement qu'espérer que
parmi votre personnel il ne va pas
trouver d'adeptes parce que là comme on
dit le ver est dans le fruit et c'est
fini mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
vision du dialogue social c'est
complètement absurde
alors on peut dire qu'effectivement dans
le secteur marchand il y a que 4 % de
présence syndicale
et souvent ce qu on nous rétorque c'est
que il y à un frein de la part des
employeurs à la présence d'organisations
syndicales pour la raison que j'avais
exposé on peut les comprendre les
patrons mais ceci dit c'est par la loi
qu'on veut imposer la présence de
syndicalistes c'est absurde c'est comme
si moi il y avait une loi qui imposait
tous mes clients à acheter du à cela
voilà quoi
c'est ce serait pas mal mais pour moi
c'est absurde aussi et ça durerait pas
longtemps on pourrait peut-être se poser
la question pourquoi y at il si peu de
présence syndicale dans les entreprises
du secteur marchand
peut-être que l'offre entre guillemets
de l'organisation syndicale est en
complet décalage avec les attentes des
salariés eux mêmes
c'est pour ça que l'esprit du rapport
combrexelle
moi je trouve c'est une magnifique
opportunité pour les partenaires sociaux
de revisiter leur corpus
logique c'est une magnifique opportunité
parce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune qui arrive
dans une entreprise mais alors là ils
sont contre fichent de savoir s'il ya
une présence syndicale ou pas il a
besoin d'un projet professionnel
avant tout il a besoin de savoir quelle
est l'ambiance de l'entreprise aussi y a
pas que le salaire c'est un tout donc je
trouve que dans cette histoire du
rapport complexe elle ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on en train de
remettre l'homme au milieu de
l'entreprise et c'est vers ça qu'il faut
aller